welcome to my list of the top things
that python noobs do. i'm also giving
away four professional licenses to pycharm, so
comment #pycharm if you want a chance to win.
some of these are actual issues for your code,
but a lot of them don't actually matter much.
nevertheless these things will tip people off to
your inexperience. so whether you're an actual
noob looking to get better, or if you just want to
catch any newbie habits that you still hold onto,
let's dive in. alright, newbie thing number
one: manual string formatting, aka putting
things together with the plus sign. instead, use
f strings. they're more readable, easier to write,
and less prone to errors. number two: manually
closing a file. i can't tell you how many beginner
tutorials recommend doing something like this.
open the file, write to it, and then call close.
if this write call throws an exception,
the file will never be closed.
instead use a with statement, which will ensure
the file is closed even if an exception is thrown.
on a similar note, number three is using
try-finally instead of a context manager.
i usually see this one from more experienced
developers but coming from a different language.
in python, most resources that need to
be closed have their own context manager,
use it. number four: using a bare except clause.
in python, keyboard interrupts and system exits
are propagated using exceptions. that means, for
example, a bare accept is going to catch something
like the user hitting ctrl-c. that's almost never
what you actually want to do. if you still want to
be lazy but you don't want to trap your user in a
box, then use an exit Exception, or if you want to
do the right thing then catch the actual exception
that's going to be thrown. number five: thinking
the carrot means exponentiation. nope, it's
bitwise xor. okay, that one's a really newbie one,
but i gotta pad the list somehow, right? number
six is: any use of default mutable arguments.
argument defaults are defined when the
function is defined, not when it's run.
in this case that means every call to the function
is sharing the same list, meaning the second time
we call it, it's not starting out as the empty
list, it's starting out as the list containing
zero from the previous call. probably not what you
wanted. if you want a mutable default, first set
it to None and then check if it's None inside the
function, setting the default there. number seven:
never using comprehensions, or if they do
use comprehensions, only list comprehensions.
a lot of code can be made both shorter
and clearer by using comprehensions.
you can have dictionary, list, set, and even
generator comprehensions. learn how to use them
when they're appropriate. number eight: _always_
using comprehensions. i get it, you just learned
about comprehensions and now it's time to flex.
but stop for a moment, you don't need to turn
every single loop into a comprehension. sometimes
this actually makes things less readable. i guess
readability is really in the eye of the beholder,
so you may not agree with this particular example,
but i hope you can agree that not every
loop should be turned into a comprehension.
number nine: checking for a type with ==. there
are some rare cases where you do want to do this,
but most of the time this is not what you want.
the reason is inheritance. a named tuple is a
tuple, so this Point class is a tuple. but it's
not literally the built-in tuple, it's a subclass.
in most cases you should program in a way where
you should be able to substitute a subclass for
its parent. this is called the Liskov substitution
principle, and checking a type for equality
is a violation of it. in most cases, what you
probably wanted instead was an isinstance check.
number 10: using == to check for None, True, and
False. instead of equality, you should check for
identity using the is comparison. this is what
== was going to do anyway, so just cut out the
middleman and use is directly. 11: using an
"if bool" or "if len" check. there's nothing
particularly wrong about these. it's just that
they're usually equivalent to just a plain "if x"
so using an "if bool" or "if length" check kind
of just shows that you don't know the language
that well. number 12: using the "range length"
idiom. a lot of beginners, especially those
coming from other languages, think about loops in
terms of indices. so they loop over the indices,
but only ever use them to grab out the elements.
instead, just loop over the underlying container
and get the elements directly. it's much easier
to read and less error prone. if you did actually
want to use the index though, you still shouldn't
use range length. use enumerate to get the index
and the element at the same time. another reason
i see people use this is to use "i" as kind of
a synchronizing variable to get corresponding
elements from two different objects. of course,
the better way to do that is using zip, and if
you still need the index use "enumerate zip".
number 13: looping over the ".keys()" of a
dictionary. don't you know, that's the default.
if you're modifying the dictionary as you're
looping over it, then it would be okay to make
a copy of the keys. depending on the situation
this might add a little bit of clarity, but even
in this case the ".keys()" is unnecessary. number
14: not knowing about the dictionary items method.
if you're looping over the keys of a dictionary
and the first thing you do is grab the value out
for each key, then what you really want is to loop
over the items of the dictionary, which are key
value pairs. number 15: not using tuple unpacking.
do you have a tuple and want to get all of its
elements out as separate variables? well you're
in luck. that's exactly what tuple unpacking does.
number 16: creating your own index counter
variable. if you're starting at zero and
adding one to something at the end of every loop,
then once again what you really want is enumerate.
number 17: using time.time to time. i think we
gotta give the noobs a break on this one. how are
they supposed to know that time.time is not for
timing your code? time.time is for telling you
what time it currently is and it's not as accurate
as using perf_counter. subtracting two subsequent
calls to perf_counter gives you the most accurate
way of measuring how much time it took your code
to run. number 18: littering your code with print
statements instead of using the logging module.
you can set up logging easily in your
main function with your own custom format.
you can also set the logging level or take it
as a parameter so you can filter out messages
that you're not interested in. there, doesn't that
look a lot better? 19: using "shell=True" on any
function in the subprocess library. "shell=True"
is the source of a lot of security problems,
and ,let's be honest, the reason you probably did
this in the first place is to avoid putting your
arguments into a list. number 20: doing math, or
pretty much any kind of data analysis, in python.
learn to use numpy for array operations and learn
to use pandas for more general data analysis,
21: using "import *" outside of an interactive
session. "import *" usually litters your
namespace with variables. instead, just import
the things you actually need. number 22:
depending on a specific directory structure for
your project. a lot of beginner code assumes
that all of your source files are going
to be in one flat source directory. they,
probably unknowingly, are depending on
the fact that when you import something
python checks for it in your system path. python
also adds the directory of the file being run
to the path, so this usually works.
however, this can really get you into
trouble if you have multiple scripts
that aren't in the same directory.
take the time to learn how to package your code
and install it into your current environment.
number 23: the common misconception that python
is not compiled. have you ever seen those ".pyc"
files next to your ".py" files? or maybe they
were in a "__pychache__" directory. those files
are compiled python code. but of course python is
also an interpreted language, so what's going on?
well python is compiled, but it's not compiled
all the way down to machine code. instead,
it's compiled to bytecode. that bytecode is then
run by the interpreter. number 24: not following
pep8. pep8 is nothing more than a style guide,
it doesn't actually affect your code at runtime.
nevertheless, your co-workers, contributors, and
friends will nag at you incessantly until you
conform. at this point, whether it actually
looks better or makes any difference at all
is kind of irrelevant. experts do it this way to
avoid the nagging. and i saved the best for last,
number 25: pretty much anything to do with python
2. python 2 hit its end of life years ago, and the
only reason you should still be using it is if you
already have millions of lines of python 2 written
and it would be too much work to migrate. all new
projects moving forward should be using python 3,
and with that comes dispelling some rumors leaking
over from python 2. even though x is really big,
this code will execute instantly. ranges
are not created in memory. even checking
if something is in a range will happen quickly.
given the endpoints of the range, you don't need
to construct all the numbers to tell whether
something is in that range, you just check how
it compares to the boundary elements, and that's
exactly what this in does. there are also things
like the changed behavior of keys. this no longer
creates a copy of the keys of the dictionary.
instead, it produces a "view". that means if
you delete a key, it'll no longer be in the
view either. there are so many of these python 2-3
things that have changed it could probably be its
own whole video, so just always be sure to check
the docs if you're not sure. as always, thank you
to my patrons and donors for supporting me. if
you liked the video, don't forget to comment,
subscribe, and slap that like button an odd number
of times. and if you especially liked the video,
please consider becoming one of my patrons
on patreon. thanks and see you next time.